اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
برلين تدين تدريبات الصين قباله تايوان
وتعتبرها تهديدا للجزيره والرئيس الصيني
يوجه الجيش بتعزيز تدريباته
وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه في وجود قوات
للنيت وفي اوكرانيا ويعتبروا تسريبات
البنتاجون مزيجا من الصدق والكذب
ايراني يصل الى الرياض لبحث اعاده فتح
السفاره والقنصليه وطهران تسعى لتنشيط
بعثاتها قبل موسم الحج المقبل
اهلا بكم بدات المناورات العسكريه التي
تجريها الصين قباله تايوان تثير قلق
العديد من الدول اذ ادانه برلين هذه
التدريبات واعتبرتها تهديدا للجزيره وذلك
قبل يوم من زياره وزيره خارجيه المانيا
الى
وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه كانت قد اشارت
الى ان 14 طائره تابعه للقوات الجويه
الصينيه عبرت خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه خط
المنتصف عند مضيق تايوان والذي يعتبر
فاصلا غير رسمي بين الجانبين هذا في حين
رصدت وزاره الدفاع خمس وثلاثين طائره
وثماني سفن صينيه حول الجزيره
الرئيس الصيني دعا من جهته القوات المسلحه
الى تعزيز التدريب العسكري من اجل قتال
فعلي واكد الرئيس الصيني ان بلاده ستدافع
بحزم عن سلامتها الاقليميه وحدودها
البحريه
وستسعى جاهده لتحقيق الاستقرار في المنطقه
واشار الى ان الصين ستعمل على ضمان
الاستجابه للتحديات المعقده وفي الوقت
المناسب
من جهه اخرى قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الصينيه انبيكين تتمتع بسياده اللا جدال
فيها على جزر بحر الصين والمياه المجاوره
وان البيان الامريكي الفلبيني يشوه
اجراءات انفاذ القانون البحري المشروعه
للصين
الصين تعرب عن قلقها واستيائها الشديدين
من البيان المشترك الصادر عن الولايات
المتحده والفلبين تتمتع الصين بسياده لا
جدال فيها على الجزر الواقعه في بحر الصين
الجنوبي والمياه المجاوره لها البيان
الامريكي الفلبيني يشوه اجراءات انفاذ
القانون البحري المشروعه للصين وينشر
شائعات وافتراءات عن الصين لا اساس لها من
الصحه
وفي احدث اجراء صينيه تجاه تايوان خفضت
بكين مده الحظر الجوي الذي تفرضه على
اجواء الجزيره الى مده قصيره جدا حيث من
المتوقع ان يؤدي مثل هذا الاجراء الى شبه
شلل لحركه الطيران جنوب وشرق اسيا
سبع وعشرون دقيقه المده المسموح بها
لتعبره هذه الاجواء شمال تايوان ذهابا
وايابا قرار فرضته السلطات الصينيه في
احدث اجراء فيما يتعلق بالجزيره التي تريد
بيكين ضمها
وزاره النقل التايوانيه قالت ان بكين
ستخفض مده حظر الطيران التي ستفرضها فوق
الشمال تايوان من سبع ساعات الى 27 دقيقه
فقط في الخطه الاوليه ولمده ثلاثه ايام
ابتداء من السادسه عشر من ابريل وحتى
الثامنه عشر من الشهر نفسه حيث سيؤثر
الامر على الستين الى 70% من الرحلات بين
الشمال شرق اسيا وجنوب شرق اسيا وزاره
الدفاع التايوانيه قالت ان الحظر مفرود من
جانب الصين وليست تايوان وان منطقه حظر
الطيران تقع في حدود منطقه التعريف الدفاع
الجوي للتايوان رجحت الوزاره ان حظر
الطيران يتعلق بشكل اساسي بنشاطات فضائيه
صينيه او اطلاق قمر اصطناعي
كانت اجرت خلال الايام القليله الماضيه
مناورات عسكريه ودفعت ببعض طائراتها
وقطاعها البحريه العسكريه الى ما بعد الخط
الذي يفصل مضيق التايوان منصفه بين
البلدين ويشكل خط المواجهه بينهما في
سيناريو لفرض حصار على الجزيره وحظر جوي
وبحري كان التقارير استخباراتيه توقعت ان
تلجا الصين الى الحصار بدلا من الغزو
المباشر حصار يبدو ان بكين بداته ب 27
دقيقه في خطتها الاوليه كما سمتها
قال وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان المعلومات
المسربه من البينتاجون هي عباره عن مزيج
من الصدق والكذب واضاف ريزنكوب الذي يزور
العاصمه الاسبانيه مدريد ان هذه التسريبات
تضمنت معلومات استفادت منها روسيا
وحلفائها ونفى وزير الدفاع الاوكراني وجود
قوات لحلف الناتو في اوكرانيا كما ورد في
هذه التشربه
ميدانيا اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
اقوات فاجنر سيطره على ثلاثه احياء سكنيه
في مدينه باخموت شرق اوكرانيا واوضحت
الدفاع الروسيه في بيانها اليومي ان
قواتها تصدت لوحده من احتياطي الجيش
الاوكراني حاولت التوغل داخل مخمل
واضاف الجيش الروسي انه احبط ونشاط ثلاث
مجموعات استطلاع عن اوكرانيه على محور
كوبيانسك في مقاطعه خاركير شمال الشرقي
اوكرانيا
اعلن المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني عن وصول وفد ايراني
الى السعوديه لاتخاذ الترتيبات اللازمه
لفتح سفاره ايران في الرياض ولفتح
قنصليتها في جده كنعاني اوضح ايضا في
تصريحات النشراتها وسائل اعلاميه ان الوفد
سيبحث في السعوديه استئناف نشاط الممثلي
الايرانيه الدائمه في منظمه التعاون
الاسلامي مشيرا الى ان طهران تسعى لفتح
بعثاتها في السعوديه
واستئناف نشاطها قبل موسم الحج المقبل هذا
وسيغادر الوفد الفني السعودي الذي وصل الى
ايران يوم السبت الماضي سيغادر متوجها الى
مشهد غدا لبحث اعاده فتح القنصليه هناك
الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
خفر السواحل التونسي ينتشل جثث عشره
مهاجرين اثر غرق مركب قباله السواحل
الشرقيه
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه استقبل نائب وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه وليد الخريجي وزير الخارجيه
السوري فيصل المقداد وذلك لدى وصول الاخير
الى مطار الملك عبد العزيز في مدينه جده
واوضحت الخارجيه السعوديه ان المقداد يزور
المملكه بدعوه من وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
الامير فيصل بن فرحان ومن المقرر عقد جلسه
مباحثات ثنائيه تتناول الجهود المبذوله
للوصول الى حل سياسي للازمه السوريه يحافظ
على وحده سوريا وامنها واستقرارها وتسهيل
عوده اللاجئين السوريين الى وطنهم وتامين
وصول المساعدات الانسانيه للمناطق
المتضرره في سوريا
اعلنت الحكومه اليمنيه تاجيل بدء عمليات
تبادل الاسرى والمعتقلين مع الحوثيين التي
كانت مقرره غدا الخميس الى الجمعه واشار
الفريق الحكومي بالمفاوضات الى ان عمليات
تبادل الاسرى ستشمل رحلات جويه بين
العاصمه صنعاء وعدن ومناطق اخرى في اليمن
بالتنسيق مع اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
كما اكد ان الاستعدادات قد اكتمل
احبطت القوات المسلحه الاردنيه بالمنطقه
العسكريه الشرقيه محاوله تسلل وتهريب
كميات من المواد المخدره قادمه من الاراضي
السوريه كما قبضت السلطات على احد
المتورطين خلال محاولاته اجتياز الحدود
بطريقه غير مشروعه الا ان بقيه المتورطين
تمكنوا من التراجع الى داخل العمق السوري
هذا وعثرت السلطات الاردنيه بعد تكثيف
عمليات البحث والتفتيش على مواد مخدره
وسلاح ناري من طراز كلاشنكوف بالاضافه الى
كميه من الذخائر
اعلن خفر السواحل التونسي انتشاله جثث
عشره مهاجرين من دول افريقيا جنوب الصحراء
اثراء غرق مركبهم قباله سواحل محافظه
صفاقس شرقي البلاد وقال المتحدث الرسمي
باسم خفر السواحل حسام الدين الجبابلي في
تصريحات لوكاله الانباء الفرنسيه انه تم
انقاذه 72 مهاجرا وانتشال عشر جثث بعدما
غرق المركب بالامس
اذا وقالت المنظمه الدوليه للهجره التابعه
للامم المتحده قالت ان اكثر من 400 مهاجر
ولاجئ غرقوا في الاشهر الاولى من عام 20
23 وذلك اثناء محاولتهم عبور البحر
المتوسط من شمال افريقيا الى اوروبا وهو
اكبر عدد من القتلى في فتره ثلاثه اشهر
خلال السنوات الست الماضيه
المنظمه وثقت
441 حاله وفاه بين يناير كانون الثاني
ومارس اذار الماضي على طريق الهجره الاكثر
تسجيلا لحالات الغرق في العالم
وقالت ان العدد الفعلي هو اكبر من هذا على
الارجح لافته الا ان نحو نصف هذه الوفيات
مرتبط بالتاخر في جهود الانقاذ
افادت رئاسه العامه لشؤون المسجد الحرام
والمسجد النبوي بوضع خطط تنظيميه جديده في
المسجد الحرام لاستقبال الموعد التكيفين
حتى نهايه شهر رمضان المبارك
وبحسب رئاسه الحرمين تصدر تصاريح الاعتكاف
الكترونيا وتستهدف اكثر من 2500 معتكف في
اماكن مخصصه لهم داخل المسجد الحرم
معي من المسجد الحرام في مكه المكرمه
مراسل العربيه نواف عزيز لمزيد من
المتابعه نواف اهلا وسهلا بك من جديد جديد
المشهد من عندك وابرز مشاهداتك اليوم نواف
نعم اتواجد الان امام باب الملك فهد وواحد
من الابواب الرئيسيه في المسجد الحرام
والتي تستقبل المعتمرين والمصلين وهذا
الباب هو ايضا واحد من الابواب التي خصصت
لاستقبال المعتكفين الذين بدا استقبالهم
منذ يوم امس في الحقيقه الخطه الجديده هي
تغيير المواقع وهي واحده من هذه المواقع
في قبو توسعه الملك فهد بالاضافه الى
مواقع اخرى في توسعه الملك عبد الله
الخطه ايضا الجديده تركز على
ضمان عدم تحرك المعتكفين الى اماكن اخرى
مما يسبب في الازدحامات او اعاقه الحركه
ويستهدف في هذه
المرحله او هذا الوقت يستهدف في الوصول
الى
2500 معتكف وفقا للطاقه التشغيليه المخصصه
الاعتكاف هنا الحركه مستمره الاقبال يعني
يعتبر منخفض مقارنه في الفتره المسائيه
وساترك لكم الان المشهد من امام باب الملك
فهد وتوسعه الملك فهد والتي في هذه
الاوقات نشهد دخول المعتمرين والمصلين
وايضا خروج الكثير من المعتمرين والمصلين
بعد بعد اداء المعتمرين
للعمره الملفت في هذه الاوقات هو وقت اداء
العمره وهو اقل من ساعتين لكل معتمر وهذا
الرصد
للعشر الوسطى في شهر رمضان يتوقع ان تزيد
هذه المده قليلا في العشر الاواخر ربما
بسبب الازدحام الكثيف والاعداد الكبيره
المتوقعه وصلنا حتى يوم امس الى اكثر من
مليون معتمر ومصمم في المسجد الحرام اكثر
من 30 مليون لتر من مياه زمزم وزعت وايضا
قياده قوات امن العمره اعلنت عن الخطط
الجديده للعشر الاواخر طيب نواف بالنسبه
للعوده الى موضوع اصدار تصاريح الاعتكاف
الكترونيا كيف يمكن للمعتمر التقدم او
تقديم على هذه التصاريح وما هي المده
المخصصه لاصدار التصريح للمعتمر او
للمعتكف
نعم قبل مده اعلن منذ بدايه رمضان اعلنت
رئاسه شؤون
المسجد الحرام والمسجد النبوي ان هناك
امكانيه لاصدار التصاريح عبر موقعها
الالكتروني
والتقدم ووفق الاجراءات التي ستتم تصدر
التصاريح قبل ايام صدرت التصاريح وحتى يوم
امس اعلنت رئاسه شؤون الحرمين اصدار الف
تصريح ووصول الف معتكف الى المسجد الحرام
بالاضافه الى المعتكفين في المسجد النبوي
في المدينه المنوره والذي بلغ عددهم نواف
عزيز مراسل العربيه من المسجد الحرام في
مكه المكرمه شكرا جزيلا لك نواف بالطبع لن
نعود اليك في نشرات لاحقه لمتابعه هذا
الموضوع
خلال زيارته لايرلندا الشماليه حيث اصول
اجداده اظهر الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
براعته في التقاط الصور الذاتيه المعروفه
بالسلفي
نشره الخامسه الموجزه لهذا اليوم انتهت
اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات